on va bien super ont commencé vous allez
ouvrir grand les yeux
à quoi pensez-vous lorsque vous voyez
ces trois images on désolé on n'a pas
parlé de rupture et ans jusque là
aujourd'hui
ils vont partager ce que j'ai appris
d'un voyage le vélo le plus de 15 km
nous sommes le 10 février 2018 nous
sommes réunis tous les sages
a lyon la baisse belvaux avec nos
familles et nos amis pendant plus des
placements de loin lors que nous aurons
la soupe et aux proviseurs sans présent
on rigole on voit manger un bout mais
dans ma tête c'est un peu fouillis je
suis partagé entre les stations au
départ la finesse de qui délègue watch
alors que j'adore passe au fait des
dernières photos et on voit l'amour à ce
moment là je crois que je ne reste pas
vraiment que je parte ou un an à 9 une
eau rejoint l'asie du sud est
le 15 janvier dernier a fait trois cent
quinze jours de voyage une vingtaine de
pays traversés
on arrive à bangkok en thaïlande c'est
la fin d'une longue aventure dans cette
année on a eu chaud on a eu froid et on
a bien galéré
on a poussé le bleu dans sa bande face
seul à rouler à des vitesses folles vont
adorer son impôt dans un local poubelle
sous un abri de bus sur le bas côté des
routes
chez les moines dans des ruines et même
dans une mosquée là qu il est petit de
montagne des grosses montagnes des
marécages et jeanne des mers et ddm on a
rencontré des chrétiens les musulmans d
un homme les bouddhistes des amériques
et aussi des gens que vous avez ce droit
on a changé les rires des souvenirs et
beaucoup de sourires bref pendant cette
année on a eu l'impression avant lui en
bout du monde une évolution lente et
douce entre l'europe de l'ouest et
l'asie du sud est
tout ça en passant par le moyen-orient
alors pourquoi je vous raconte tout ça
si je suis là aujourd'hui c'est parce
que j'aimerais vous inviter à
expérimenter expérimenté comment l'as tu
aimes ce voyage se lancer dans l'inconnu
pour aller vers de nouveaux horizons
sortir les hommes de coupe en pour
tenter un nouveau défi et il n'aimait
pas dire demain santé tout ce garage est
parti faire le tour du monde l'idée
d'agir et d'oseille nous est chouette un
rêve un projet une envie au système
qu'est ce que vous allez pourquoi
expérimenté exactement parce que grâce à
ce voyage
grâce à toutes ces nouvelles
d'expérience j'ai appris une chose
essentielle
j'ai appris à me connaître en cette
année j'ai découvert sa tête dominique
physique et certaines vignettes mental
j'ai découvert certaines choses qui me
plaisait aux concertos qui me déplaisait
j'ai appris à vivre en groupe en
permanence et trouver ma place
ça m'a permis de mieux comprendre mes
envies mes attentes mais besoin pour
nous à les exprimer ou encore découvrir
de nouvelles facettes de ma mère sonnait
et toutes ces belles rencontres avec des
gens d'univers de religion de culture
des violences
eh bien ils ont été une source
d'inspiration de réflexion et de remise
en question seul
alors pourquoi je voudrais je vais
prendre plus ou moins de protection
lorsque je suis parti je voulais
terminer les doodles j'avais plus de
responsabilités encore de job pas de
famille pas de chien pas de mauvaise
passe mais seulement j'avais peur de
jeter lendemain du travail et me lancer
pour les 40 prochaines années sans
vraiment savoir si j'étais prêt sans
vraiment savoir ce dont j'avais envie je
crois que j'avais peur de prendre une
décision et le retrouver
en plus de ça vous poser plein de
questions sérieuses télé sur son futur
sur ma carrière sur la place dans la
société
62 mais d'action où ma contribution à la
communauté
aujourd'hui ils vont être avec vous
après ce voyage je n'ai pas trouvé de
réponse idéale à toutes ces questions
sérieuses mais maintenant je ressens
moins de questions chansons moins de
pression pardon dans les choix d'une
prise de décision parce que j'ai pris
conscience de l'importance d'apprendre à
se connaître
l'importante de découvrir ce dont on a
envie et aussi souvent qu'on n'a pas
envie ensuite savoir la nouvelle
aujourd'hui je me sens libéré et je me
dis bah ce gamin continue expérimenté
vous regarde et je me suis un peu entre
vaud qui disent peut-être mais si pour
toi tu la fais tu as réussi et moi j'ose
pas je sais pas par où commencer
ça me fait peur tout ça alors que l'on
s'y prendre je ne vais pas vous donner
la recette miracle mais j'aimerais vous
raconter quatre petites histoires que
j'ai vécu pendant sept années et dont
j'ai tiré les enseignements de la
peut-être cela pourra peut-être viser
plusieurs fois au cours de ce voyage
on a rencontré vêtements clairs intrigué
ce nom des monnaies comme ça avec nos
vélos à gauche on leur répondait pour
les france et ça faisait plusieurs mois
qu'on voyage
la réaction est souvent à mains d'abord
les journées du temps à comprendre nous
regardent d'un air les bananes alors on
sent le compteur est là tout s'éclaircit
ensuite c'est drôle parce qu'ils
s'imaginent l'instant neuf places et
nous disent sauvez moi jamais je
pourrais faire ça moi aussi au début
quand je suis parti j'ai des vertex je
suis parti de lyon j'avais jamais volé
plus de 50 kilomètres en une journée et
encore moins plusieurs jours de suite
avec le poil et sa poche
j'avais l'impression
chats et les premières semaines qu'ils
n'étaient pas plus rassurés quand je
pense à tous ces pays pour l'imprévu
traversé toutes ces dix tous et dysport
tous ces kilomètres ça me faisait peur
j'avais l'impression d'avoir devant moi
de montagne gigantesque avec un sommet
inaccessible au fur et à mesure que les
jours s'enchaîner j'ai pris confiance en
moi j'ai senti qu'on porte sur bitume
progressivement l'exercice que je n'ai
plus en plus fort et progressivement ma
passion la première trajet debout
différentes
je le regardais plus qu'il restait à
faire et tout ce qu'on avait déjà fait
je ne regardais de l'objectif final est
plutôt un objectif intermédiaire comme
quand la prochaine frontière où la ville
étape de la soirée kilomètre après
kilomètre
jour après jour on a fait le premier
membre semaine après semaine mois après
mois on a réussi en quelques mois à
partir de ce moment là j'ai compris
poursuit son attention sur un objectif
plus concret est moins ambitieux ça vous
rassurer et même si j'avais même si je
savais que j'en sais plus doucement je
savais qu'il a lancée sur mon objectif
final on a beaucoup et bien on a aussi
aimé trouver une nouvelle combines pour
éviter portel attendre je vous explique
à la fin de la journée on avait pris
l'habitude d'aller dormir d'alep d'aller
dîner chez les restaurants routiers
on attendait la fin du repas on leur
demandait gentiment cd possible de
dormir
généralement ils accepter alors dans un
coin entre de tam en installer nos
valeurs et nos cuvées et endormie qu'un
début un jour à midi en cherchant la
baisse soit en compte que j'ai oublié au
restaurant de la veille 40 kg et nine
j'étais dégoûté
là je dis aux gars asie seront
impossibles et je vous rattraper sur la
rue ponty vélo et j'arrive juste avant
la mue en restaurant les saveurs se
souviennent de moi et comprennent que
j'arrive
le patron qu'on n'avait pas vu la veille
arrivées se présente je suis une
situation on commence à discuter est
intéressé par le voyage ils nous
proposent de dinars et et j'accepte
alors passé toute la soirée
en fin de repas includes bien dormir
chez moi et demain je t'emmènerai gars
tu m'épates de l'emprunt sera plus
passer pour le développement je n'ai
superbement lendemain matin au petit
déjeuner il a dit tu vas 4,4 d'avoir et
coutumes et pour mes looks denrées en
fait je te remet directement retrouver
des copains savais pas comment m'en
lasser et là je peux vous dire que votre
les copains m'ont vu arriver le
lendemain en 4-4-2 l'eau derrière et le
patron du restaurant volant il l'avait
surpris de voir aussitôt après cette
histoire j'ai pris conscience d'une
chose on ne peut pas tout contrôler on a
beau se préparer au maximum
essayez d'anticiper les risques les
erreurs les oublie il ya toujours d'un
premier on est d'accord retard et c'est
frustrant
et si on réussit à changer l'état
d'esprit et avoir confiance quand le
changement de cap pour réussir à
apprécier la prévenue parce que
l'imprévu il pleut année le positif le
moment je me suis rendu compte que j'ai
oublié ma vez j'étais dégoûté et
finalement j'ai passé une super soirée
et gésiers super envie parce que parfois
tu te retrouves sur un chemin qui est
différente mutu est prévu prendre
et finalement ce smart apporte autant de
satisfaction que celui que tu aimerais
prendre ces sages en a
travers cette petite distance a été un
des moments les foules challenger de
google
le tadjikistan c'est un tout petit pays
notre pays d'asie centrale dont je ne
connaissais même pas loin de partir
toute la partie est du pays est
recouverte de montagne et des hauts
plateaux qui s'élèvent à plus de 4000
mètres d'altitude
cette région la région du camion la
région dgac
des youyous et mélomanes lorsqu'on la
pleine lune voyage on avait essayé
d'aller là bas parce qu'on avait lu sur
des blogs qui a une route incroyable il
traverse la rue ses troupes c'est la
première règle
cédric été construit pour les
soviétiques dans les années 30 pour que
les troupes militaires puissent
traverser le pays et rejoint le petit
stand
depuis quand le pm oreca régions isolées
par uta pas vraiment été à la mode
bref en choisissant des là-bas ou star
is like l'épreuve on savait qu'on allait
manger la piste du dénivelé et latitude
on savait aussi qu'on allait devoir les
monts l'autonomie plusieurs jours de
suite mais à ce moment là j'étais bien
loin d'imaginer à quel point on à
l'heure de l'est pas ce que je peux vous
dire on a bouffé la buissière on a roulé
à des vitesses tellement londres est
montée quand lorsqu'une compris qu'ils
étaient plus à des gens que vous aimez
l'eau et on est esprit crème des
pommiers descente pour la commencer a
pris le bon dieu pour que le blog
cerveau a aussi découvert qu'il était
capable de manger le riz les jours de
suite
matin et soir il ya une chose une chose
avec quatre jours maintenant
encore moins les choses c'était la
maladie les maladies gastriques on sait
d'ailleurs échangé autour de moi c'est
elle qui à plusieurs reprises map les
dire j'en ai marre je retrouvais mon
livre je prends une douche chaude
il arrête les conneries on rentre à la
maison pour tout vous dire quand j'ai
quitté le tadjikistan je me suis juré de
ne jamais revenir
aujourd'hui en y repensant j'arrive à
prendre la pleine mesure de ce qu'on a
j'en suis fier ça m'a fait réaliser que
la difficulté était belle parce qu'après
coup elle devait changer de regard
elle te fait changer de regard parce que
tu te sens satisfait d'avoir été capable
de dépasser
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu soit au
point de vous dire vous allez passer
et bien si j'ai un conseil à vous donner
et mettez une surprise histoire peut
moduler pour comprendre pourquoi il
suffit de regarder quoi ça ressemble au
sien du désert d état et encore lorsque
la préparer le voyage
on sait que ça va être un défi mais je
peux vous dire pour les wizards 50
degrés la journée 30 degrés la nuit on a
mis trop de l'organisation lever à 3
heures du matin pour décoller aux
aurores voulait jusqu'à 11h 12h traité
pendant les heures les plus chaudes
avant de repartir le soir pour trois
spots de mémoire et comme ce n'est pas
assez fun et voilà une news à 3
seulement vise la troisième de cinq
jours pour traverser les 500 kilomètres
qui séparent les deux postes-frontières
lundi prochain bref aux pendant cinq
jours on a vécu une véritable course
contre la montre les premiers jours la
liste sono était complexe et on arrivait
toujours à débrouiller et la voix la
région en l'échappée du jour là c'est
particulier parce que les points les
points de ravitaillement souvenirs plus
limité on peut compter que sur les
stations essence alors que le voir on
étudie la carte on l'a repéré leurs
positions au kilomètre 60 on s'arrête à
la deuxième station ont fait le plein
d'eau et comme il est 10 heures ausy que
nous pousser jusqu'à la prestation avant
de repartir on confirme la position avec
le bund 10 ans reprend la route avec
suffisamment d'eau pour seniors
le meurtre en plus tard on irait
montfrin on a utilisé est presque à vide
au mais heureux et soulagé dieppe
enfin ça c'était avant de s'apercevoir
que le bâtiment est fermé et qui a
personne dedans à ce moment là on se
regarde tous et on comprend que ça fait
chaud chez soi
j'ai d'abord je sèche je crois que
l'entente ne déshydraté j'ai du mal à
réussir la prochaine station énorme 1 km
soit encore deux heures avec le banc la
fatigue la chaleur de midi bref ce jour
là si on n'avait pas trouvé un peu d'eau
au fond d'une vieille cage rouillée
je ne sais pas dans quel rôle vous voyez
si j'ai réussi à aller au bout de cette
épreuve de toute épreuve
c'est en grande partie parce que j'étais
tombé seul je n'aurais seul je n'aurais
pas fait seul je ne serais pas partie en
cette année on a pu compter et se
reposer les uns sur les autres dans les
moments durs ce qui était un peu mieux
encourager ce qui est d'un peu moins de
l'ain et concéder la panique à bord ce
qui était plus lucides apporter la carte
est plus gros alors oui je proviens seul
on va plus vite mais ensemble on va plus
loin
alors aujourd'hui après citer les
voyages et ses 15000 kilomètres à vélo
j'ai tiré plusieurs enseignements entre
autres j'ai compris ce que l'isr
d'expression un éléphant ça se mange une
bouchée la toile
ensuite j'ai appris à écrire l'imprévu
avec confiance et sérénité
puis j'ai appris à m'accrocher dans les
difficultés
enfin j'ai pris conscience de
l'importance de bien son coin voyez
toutes ces apprentissages toutes ces
expériences
tous ces enseignements ils m'ont aidé
beaucoup de ces défis et ils m'aideront
pour espérer monter à nous parce que
vous aussi en expérimentant de nouvelles
choses et en sortant de notre zone de
confort vous apprendrez à vous découvrir
vous apprendrez à découvert qui
d'essence pour vous est ce qui vous
passionne expérimenté pour apprendre à
se connaître
c'est peut-être là une église
[Applaudissements]